[Applause]
a beautiful fall morning reflecting on
the light that comes after Darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
the one October Massacre Las Vegas is
still reeling from that tragic night but
the community Has Come Together in so
many ways since then including the Vegas
strong 5K
[Music]
taking place just seven weeks after the
shooting it has now become an annual
event our intent was just to have it the
first year but after everybody came
together and coming together with
support and love and healing and they
just said please have it every year the
race has raised quarter of a million
dollars each penny going to scholarships
and victim funds though this weekend has
been a reminder of the heartache from
that dark night it allowed survivors and
families of victims to take another step
forward together my cousin was amazing
she was 22 years old and full of life
laughter she loved country music she
loved to sing dance and and she was just
an amazing person her smile was
contagious it was a heartbreaking moment
I heard that news when I wake up in the
morning ready to go to work
I cannot believe that happening right in
front of my working place a run to
always remember and to never forget we
are Vegas strong
Victoria Saha 8 News Now